cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de nausicaa l'oeuvre majeure du maître
de l'animation miyazaki sortie au japon
il ya plus de vingt ans une fable
écologique qui devrait fasciné toutes
les générations et issia fernandez
philippe et endo imaginer une terre
dévastée par la folie des hommes où
seuls quelques survivants lutterait
contre l'avancée inexorable d'une mère
toxiques et de gigantesques 20 7
mi-temps les homos et puis imaginez une
jolie princesse répondant au doux nom de
nausicaa originaire de la vallée du vent
désireuse de sauver l'humanité quel
endroit étrange très politique et
personnel nos écoles est considéré comme
un chef-d'oeuvre de miyazaki j'ai trouvé
ton planeur
comment tu te sens il aura fallu
attendre plus de vingt ans pour le voir
en salle enfants le présenter je suis à
ce bel du royaume de paix jt seuls
quelques-uns conditionnelle l'avait déjà
vue sur petit écran
c'était une version tronquée ou qui
avaient été diffusés contre le contre
l'avis de miyazaki quand il a vu ça il a
été été révoltés parce qu'on avait coupé
beaucoup trop de zinc d'histoire on
avait on avait changé la musique etc
enfin complètement dénaturé la nature de
son film jusqu'à ce qu'on lui trouve une
offre une solution acceptable avec
disney mais très longtemps après toutes
les obsessions du maître de l'animation
japonaise sont là la défense de la
nature
la croyance en des forces l'invisible
m'utilise croire d'un monde meilleur et
pacifié vous comptez faire pour
l'exterminer asbl qui est cette jeune
fille
nausicaä de la vallée du vent c'est elle
qui m'a sauvé la vie
vallée du vent je représente mon idéal
d'êtres humains celui que j'aurais voulu
devenir celui que j'aurais voulu
rencontrer celui que j'aurais voulu voir
sur la terre
au japon le succès de nausicaa fut tel
que miyazaki pu créer ses propres six
lieux d'animation les studios ghibli
depuis de nombreux chefs-d'oeuvre y ont
vu le jour